In honor of to tell the truth, we wanted to see
if you would tell us the truth
or not in this round of final five.
Will you do that with us?
I'm with it.
All right, round of final five!
(crowd cheering)
(drum roll)
It's my favorite game on the show.
Okay, I'm gonna read off five statements about you
and you're going to let us know if it's true or false,
and our studio audience can get involved by giving
a thumbs up if they think it's true and a thumbs down
if you think it's false.
All right, you once ordered a jacuzzi
on your mom's credit card without asking her?
Thumbs up or thumbs down?
I have a lot of thumbs up in the room.
Thumbs up.
The answer is no.
Oh!
(applause)
I ordered a baby grand piano at 11, not a jacuzzi.
At 11?
At 11.
And then what happened?
Oh, I got my (bleep) beat.
Yeah, I was like, "I have a feeling that thing
went bad."
Okay, you were a delivery mascot.
Is that true or false?
Oh, I' see a thumbs down over there.
A couple thumbs downs.
Thumbs up.
(crowd cheering)
(applause)
Deliver mascot for a gourmet dessert delivery company
while I was a freshman, sophomore at Howard university.
My character's name was captain cravings.
(crowd laughs)
I gotta tell you this.
We might be short on time.
My outfit was black dance tights, sparkle Chuck All stars,
a silver long ranger mask, silver gloves
and a pink cape that said,
"If you ever need to be saved, dial 797 crave."
(crowd cheers)
(applause)
And a white sweatshirt.
I wasn't topless, I had a white sweatshirt,
and it said, "Captain cravings."
I wanna see a picture of that.
Do you have any pictures?
Oh no, thank God I don't.
Well, I have it in my mind.
Okay, you drink a gallon of milk every day.
Y'all know black people are lactose intolerant,
you know that's false.
I drink a gallon of water a day.
Okay, you own three to four hundred pairs of shoes.
True or false?
You guys saw Black-ish, it's true.
(crowd laughs)
I got one hell of a shoe closet.
You're a sneaker head, right?
I'm a sneaker head.
Okay, you won $250,000 on Who Wants to Be a Millionaire.
True or false?
A lot of falses.
Interesting.
Oh, brother, you don't think I could win a quarter
of a million dollars on Who Wants to Be a Millionaire?
I was riding with you on all of those questions,
those answers you were giving me!
The answer is true, I won a quarter of a million dollars
for Alzheimer's.
That's one of my favorite games,
Who Wants to Be a Millionaire.
Congratulations on that.
Thank you.
So as a last question, I just wanna say, and ask,
how does it feel to send off with a chef's kiss,
if you will, the beautiful show, Black-ish,
which was just one of its kind.
(crowd cheers)
So revered.
Thank you.
So accoladed.
How do you feel about?
I feel great with what we were about,
what we were able to accomplish over eight seasons.
Subject matter is racism, colorism, sexism,
postpartum depression, politics, all of those things.
And edutain people with that.
And thank all of you guys,
and thank everyone at home for watching.
Thank you.
(crowd cheers)
(applause)
Anthony Anderson, for more information about
his campaign, go GetRealAboutDiabetes.com
You can find it on our website.
(crowd cheers)
(applause)
Or on his website.
(upbeat music)